네. 안녕하세요. 요즘에 빌딩 시장이
매우 뜨거워지고 있습니다. 어, 정말
10조를 넘은게 2022년 2021년
뭐 그때 이제 호황장 때 10조를
넘었었는데 거래 건수 같은 경우에는
1분기 기준으로 한 16% 정도가
늘어났고 거래 기준으로는 무려
43%나 늘어났습니다. 물론 이제
대형 빌딩 거래들이 많이 일어나긴
했지만 실제로 거래 건수가 좀 많이
늘어났어요. 그래서 여기서 또 보셔야
될게 전국 그 상업 업무용 부동산
중에 한 60% 정도가 서울에서
이뤄지고 있습니다. 그래서 서울시
위주로 빌딩들이 많이 거래되고
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같고 10억대
미만 꼬마 빌딩이라고 불리는 그 정도
금액대 거래 건수가 전체 거래에게
63%가 될 정도로 정말 작은
빌딩들이 거래가 많이 됐습니다. 그
이유가 뭐냐면 어 몇억으로 대출받아
살 수 있는 그런 주택 투자자분들이
빌딩 시장으로 많이 넘어오기
시작했습니다. 그러면서 거래 건수가
최근에 좀 많이 늘어나고 있습니다.
예전에는 빌딩을 만약에 매입한다라고
하면 임차인이 알아서 들어오겠지.
요즘 트렌드는 그냥 보유하고 있는게
아니라 어떻게 운영하고이 건물을
어떻게 브랜드와 할 건지가 되게 좀
트렌드인 거 같아요. 역삼역 인근에
되게 낡은 건물이 하나 있었거든요.
대표적인 사례가 스파크 플러스 이제
공유 오피스 업체가 역삼역 인근에
있는 건물을 통째로 들어와서 여기에
공유 오피스뿐만 아니라 라운지 그리고
스튜디오까지 만들어서이 공간을
브랜드화 해서 수익률을 극대화한
사례가 있습니다. 두 번째로는 요즘에
그 성수동 되게 핫하잖아요. 예전에
뉴욕의 브루클린에서 보여 드렸던
것처럼 이런 공장들을 리모델링해서
요즘 핫한 그런 브랜드들이 들어오거나
MG들이 좀 이런 거 되게
좋아하거든요. 색다른 곳에서 경험하는
거. 지금 성수동가 보시면 웬만한
공장들을 그냥 리모델링 해 가지고
임대를 주거나 어 이렇게 사회용하는
경우가 되게 많아요. 어 지금 실제로
그렇게 바꿔 놓으니까 이런 젊은
사람들이 많이 들어오고 있고 그
공간에 뭐 팝업 스토어라든지 기업들이
이런 공간을 좀 멋있게 만들어 가지고
지금 성수동이 어 이런 젊은 사람들이
가장 인기가 많은 그런 지역이 된 거
같습니다. 외국인들도 이쪽을 좀 많이
찾고 있어요. 그래서 외국인들도 한국
왔을 때 그냥 우리가 봤을 때
일반적인 상권에 일반적인 빌딩에 이런
골층 빌딩에 들어와 있는 임차인이
아니라 진짜 좀 색다르고 어 이런
공장 느낌인데 거기를 리모델링 해
가지고 좀 색다른 공간으로 만든 그런
공간들을 되게 선호해서 외국인들도
많이 찾는 어 그런 핫한 지역으로 좀
변했습니다. 예전에는 이제 신축도
많이 했어요. 근데 요즘 같은
경우에는 신축비가 워낙 많이 오르고
공사기가 쉽지 않아졌거든요. 기간도
오래 걸리고 리모델링 건수가 좀 많이
늘어났습니다. 그리고 앞으로 저는
이런 리모델링 건수가 더 많이 늘어날
것으로 예상이 돼요. 어, 앞으로 뭐
이렇게 공장을 리모델링 한다든지 진짜
낡은 여관을 뭐 바꾼다든지 뭐 이런
리모델링 하는 그런 공간들이 많아질
것으로 예상이 돼서 그렇게 좀
트렌드가 좀 많이 바뀌고 있습니다.
플레이어에 따라서 건물 가치가
달라지고 유동인 거가 달라지고 공간
활용도라든지 이런게 좀 많이
달라진다라고 생각을 하거든요.
여러분들이 지금 빌딩 투자하신다라고
하면 단순하게 나 건물주야. 뭐 임대
맞치면 얼마에 맞출 수 있어. 이런게
아니라 내가 어떤 플레이어를이 공간에
넣을지를 고민을 해야 돼요. 제가
봤을 때는 요즘 같은 시기에는 첫
번째라고 생각합니다. 요즘에 워낙
공실이 많기 때문에 임대가 진짜 쉽지
않거든요. 그래서 임대를 어떻게
마치느냐에 따라서 건물 가치도 완전
달라지기도 합니다. 저는 앞으로 더
플레이어의 시대가 될 거 같아요.
그래서 지금 위에 말씀드렸던 사례처럼
이런 플레이어를 어떻게 드릴지,
플레이어들이 어떤 공간을 좋아할지를
좀 더 고민해 보시고 그렇게
리모델링하거나 임차인들이 들어올 수
있게 미리 전략을 짜서 아니면 미리
컨택을 해서 뭐 같이 할 수도
있겠죠. 플레이어들이 좋아할 만한
곳, 그런 건물들을 찾아서 투자를
해야지 공실 리스크도 좀 줄이고
가격도 많이 오를 거라고 생각을
하거든요. 그리고 요즘에 공실이 워낙
많다 보니까 고시원으로 수익률을
얼마까지 늘릴 수 있다. 뭐 이런
얘기들이 굉장히 많은데 저는
개인적으로 고시원을 허가 받기도 좀
어렵고 그리고 뭐 소방법이라든지 그런
리스크들이 되게 많아요. 고시텔 같은
경우에는 직접 거주를 하기 때문에
컴플레인이 굉장히 심하거든요. 그래서
요즘 같은 때 이렇게 비가 많이
오거나 이런 누수 이슈가 있거나
하면은 관리에 대한 리스크도 굉장히
크거든요. 그래서 단순하게 고시원
수익률 많이 나온다고 해서 투자를
했다가 남은 패를 보는 경우도 굉장히
많거든요. 고시원 건물 같은 경우에는
나중에 매각할 때 그 고시원 방마다
반개수 차감을 해요. 그래서 대출이
안 나옵니다. 그래서 오히려 팔 때는
용도 변경을 하거나 아니면 방을 다
부신 다음에 파는게 더 이득일 수도
있어요. 나중에 매각도 안 되는
경우도 많거든. 물론 이제 주거에
대한 수요는 저는 앞으로 더 많아질
거고 임대료도 굉장히 좀 높아질
거라고 생각을 하지만 지금 행정적으로
어찌 됐든 세금 이슈라든지 나중에
매각대 이슈라든지 이런 부분 때문에
어 이런 고시텔이나 주거용 투자는 좀
더 신중히 접근해야 되지 않나 이렇게
저는 생각을 하고 있습니다. 그래서
앞으로 빌딩 전망을 저는 뭐
2025년 하반기도 그렇고 내년까지도
빌딩 거래량이 그래도 계속 늘어날
것으로 예상이 돼요. 금리도 많이
내려가고 유동성도 많이 좋아졌고
그리고 주택 가격이 한번 올랐잖아요.
그래서 주택 투자자분도 실제로 빌딩
시장에 많이 들어오고 있고 그리고
지금 주식 시장도 굉장히 좀
좋잖아요. 주식 투자하셨던 분들도
실제로 빌딩 시장으로 많이 넘어오고
있습니다. 빌딩 거래량은 계속 늘어날
것으로 예상이 되는데 근데 양극한은
되게 심해지고 그리고 지금 그
자영업자분들은 굉실에
대한 리스크가 워낙 크기 때문에
여러분들이 확실히 플레이어들을 들어갈
만한 그런 건물들을 투자하는게 이런
리스크를 줄일 수 있다라고 생각하고
미리 사전에 체크를 해 가지고
수익률을 좀 올릴 수 있게 어 미리
준비를 하시면 이런 리스크를 줄일 수
있다라고 저는 생각을 합니다.네
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요.
다음 시간에 뵙겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]